thank you all for braving this heatwave
and coming here on a Saturday afternoon
we're really excited this is actually
the fifth year we've done the female
founders conference and our first time
in New York so I'm very happy to be here
and have you all here so I'm Jessica
Livingston I co-founded Y Combinator
which was the first accelerator today
there are thousands all over the world
at least hundreds all over the world but
in 2005 what we were doing was so
unusual that people in Silicon Valley
just regarded us is very irrelevant Y
Combinator began the same way as most
other startups with a hypothesis about
something we thought people wanted and
it turns out they did want it and we
grew and grew
now we've funded more than 1,800
startups with a total value of over a
hundred billion dollars so having myself
been through the kind of startup journey
that many of you are hoping to I wanted
to tell you my own story now if you only
know me through the media you might get
the impression that my contribution to Y
Combinator is that I'm Paul Graham's
wife
and while I love being his wife there is
a little bit more to the story than that
so I was born in Minneapolis in 1971
later that year my mother left home
weaving my father alone with a small
baby so he took me back to Boston where
my grandmother lived and I lived with my
grandmother during the week while my dad
worked and I lived with my dad on
weekends my grandmother was the most
important female role model in my life
she was a very independent person and
the term anyone who knew her would use
to describe her is free-spirited for
example in the wintertime after putting
me to bed she'd go out and work till
late in the evening on these giant ice
sculptures that she build in our front
yard she did what she wanted and she
didn't care if people thought she was
unconventional so despite growing up
without a mother my childhood was really
happy my dad made a lot of sacrifices so
I could get a great education and he
constantly encouraged me I played soccer
when I was younger and when I was in the
ninth grade we had an away game at a
school called Phillips Academy in
Andover Mass and the place seemed so
unbelievably fabulous that I decided
right there on the spot that I was going
to go to school there little did I know
though that this decision would have
bittersweet consequences in my old
school I'd been a big fish in a small
pond I was a straight-a student and good
at sports and when I got to Andover in
the fall of 1986 it seemed like everyone
was straight-a students and good at
sports so I got really discouraged and
basically gave up I defaulted to being a
mediocre student and did nothing
impressive or noteworthy for the next
decade it was like my own personal Dark
Ages
and it's a bit embarrassing to reflect
on to be honest with you but I think
it's important to mention because when
journalists and biographers write about
successful founders they often focus on
early predictors of success in people's
formative years and for me you know I
didn't have these things and I didn't at
least have any of the conventional kind
of predictors and no one would have
voted me most likely to succeed but
while I had no achievements I did have
three defining characteristics when I
was younger that were critical in making
Y Combinator work the first was the
quality that caused my YC co-founders to
nickname me the social radar I was one
of those kids who just couldn't get
anything passed if something seemed off
or out of character
I noticed and made inquiries I was
always trying to figure things out based
on subtle social cues the second was
that I never liked being at the mercy of
anyone else I hated anyone telling me
what to do or not to do parents teachers
bosses people had to collaborate with
but disagreed with anyone
and the third distinctive thing about me
was that I've pretty much always been a
straight shooter my grandmother and my
father were both like that but I'll come
back to those in a minute the day after
I graduated from college my beloved
grandmother died it was really sad and
lonely time in my life and now I was
supposed to find a job with a degree in
English and absolutely no clue what I
wanted to do I wound up getting a job at
fidelity investments in our customer
service group answering calls from 3:30
til midnight every day
physically talking to retail investors
about why their Magellan account was
down that day
whose awful I didn't love the job but I
did love having a job working hard and
getting paid for it and not having
homework hanging over my head it was
great and after fidelity I worked in
investor relations in New York City then
at Food & Wine magazine and at an
automotive consulting firm and I even
worked briefly for a wedding planner in
2003 I was working in the marketing
department at an investment bank in
Boston when I first met Paul Graham at a
party at his house one night we started
dating and I felt like I finally had met
mr. right despite having quite different
backgrounds we were really similar if I
thought I never wanted to be at the
mercy of someone else
Paul was that dialed up to 11 he'd moved
back to Cambridge after selling his
startup via web to Yahoo and he was at
the time writing essays working on
programming languages publishing a book
and curing his debilitating fear of
flying by learning to hang glide of all
things Paul is the best problem solver
I've ever met he's also a genius at
expanding ideas and making radical
improvements to things one of his
defining characteristics is telling
people you know what you should do if
you know me to find that very funny I'm
sure I'd say it to you Paul and his
circle of friends exposed me to this new
world of startups and it felt much more
exciting than the later stage of
publicly traded companies that I was
involved with at the investment bank I
read the book startup by Jerry Kaplan
without his pen computing company called
go and I was just immediately hooked it
was like some light shining down from
the heavens and I wanted to hear more
stories about the early days of startups
so I started working on a book of
interviews with startup founders and the
book was called founders at work and it
was
published in 2007 at the same time I was
becoming more interested in startups I
was becoming less interested in my job
the bubble had burst a few years back
and the investment bank was making some
pretty drastic cutbacks and you know
working there just had become boring and
unpleasant so I applied for a job at a
venture capital firm where I felt like I
might be one step closer to this
exciting world of startups and while I
was interviewing at the VC firm Paul
would you know what you should do me
each night at dinner telling me how I
should change the VC business once I got
into it we talked for hours about how
broken early-stage funding was and most
importantly how more people would start
startups if it could be made easier for
them so as the VC firm took longer and
longer to decide to hire me the ideas
grew more and more compelling until one
night Paul just said let's just start
our own the next day we convinced Paul's
co-founders from via Web Robert and
Trevor to join us part time and the
initial plan was that they would pick
and advise the startups and I would do
everything else instead of giving large
amounts of money to small numbers of
established companies like traditional
VC's did we'd give small amounts of
money to large numbers of earlier stage
startups and then we'd give them a lot
of help and our initial target audience
was programmers who we felt could handle
the technical aspects of startup but
were clueless about everything else just
like Paul Robert and Trevor had been we
also had more faith in young founders
than most investors did back then
I mean this was back in the days when
Google's VCS had invest insisted that
the founders hire an outside CEO as a
condition of their series-a around so
none of us had any experienced angel
investing
and that's where the idea of funding
startups in batches came from we decided
to fund a whole bunch of startups at
once during the summer so that we could
learn how to be investors in March 2005
we launched Y Combinator's website and
invited people to apply for what we
called the summer founders program we
funded eight startups that summer and we
recognized almost immediately the power
of investing in batches it was so much
better for the founders they had
colleagues to help them during you know
a time that had previously been a very
lonely process but it was also a much
more efficient way for us to help the
startups because we could do things for
them all at once
every Tuesday night Paul cooked dinner
for them and at each dinner we brought
in a guest speaker to teach the founders
about startups Paul talked to all the
startups about what they were building
and I hope to get them all incorporated
as C corporations and this was a really
big deal in those days actually because
back then to become a C Corp you had to
pay a lawyer like fifteen thousand
dollars to do this for you the first
summer we gave the startups $6,000 per
founder which was based on the stipend
that MIT gave students gave their grad
students during the summer at the end of
the summer we hosted demo day for an
audience of about 15 investors which we
were very excited about reddit was in
that first batch and the founders of
twitch although they were working on a
different idea and Sam Altman's
geolocation startup and that we only had
tried funding a batch of startups as a
way to learn how to be investors we
realized it within a couple of weeks
that we were onto something promising so
we decided to do all of our investing in
batches and we also decided that we'd
fund the next batch in Silicon Valley we
knew that a lot of people would copy us
and we didn't want someone else to be
the Y Combinator of Silicon Valley we
wanted to be that ourselves so despite
the fact that we've grown significantly
over the past you know 13 years and
we've expanded in a lot of different
ways ycs core program is remarkably
similar to what it was in 2005 so the
question I always used to get over the
years from people was so what is your
role at YC and it used to really bug me
because no one ever asked Paul Robert or
Trevor that question but now I think
it's kind of an interesting question to
think about what was my role as the only
non-technical founder of Y Combinator
well at the beginning there were tons of
errands like with any startup that just
had to get done and there was no one
else to do them Paul and I divided up
responsibilities perfectly which I think
is very important if you happen to start
a start-up with your spouse or your
partner he made our website and
application and I got all the other
stuff set up for the first summer I
worked with the lawyers to set up Y
Combinator the entity and to help create
all kinds of template legal paperwork
for our standard investments and
everything that the founders would need
to set up their companies and assign
stock properly and if you've ever done
that you know it's a lot of paperwork to
do and I had to learn quickly about how
to advise them on filling everything out
so that they wouldn't have to pay the
legal fees I had to set up Paul's small
office building in Cambridge to be our
weekly dinner gathering space for 25
people I set up our bank account and I
contacted people to speak at our our
dinners every week I bought the
groceries that Paul cooked for the
dinners I even delivered air
conditioners that I bought at Home Depot
to the founders I mean I was really the
only one of us organized enough to make
all this kind of stuff happen
when it came to investing I had
something that my co-founders didn't
have I was a social radar
I couldn't judge our applicants
technical ability or even most of their
ideas my co-founders were experts at
those things I looked at qualities the
applicant of the applicants that my
co-founders couldn't see did they seem
earnest did they seem determined were
they flexible minded and most
importantly what was the relationship
between the co-founders like well my
partner's just discussed the idea with
the applicants I usually sat observing
silently and afterward they turned to me
and asked should we fund them from the
beginning I was very careful about only
funding earnest people back then I never
envisioned that the the people we funded
would grow into this community of
thousands of YC alumni but I always
tried to create an [ __ ] free culture
if I could tell someone was a conceited
[ __ ] we did not fund them and I'm
sure we've since funded some conceited
[ __ ] but early on I was pretty rigid
about this and I think that's the basis
of the culture of our alumni community
so so far the stuff might sound a bit
different than you'd expect in a
successful investor but when you get to
an extreme in something
things get qualitatively different Y
Combinator was a new extreme in the
venture funding business so what made
someone a good investor was different
feces relied on growth figures and
estimates of market sizes but those
didn't exist at the stage that we were
investing what YC needed was deeply
technical people to judge the potential
of an idea and then someone like me to
understand the founders characters and
the relationships between them
and to do that well you needed abilities
that had previously not been considered
important as an investor it was doubly
hard too because some of the applicants
were so young we had to judge the
founders not by what they were but what
they could turn into
I mean imagine Mark Zuckerberg back in
his dorm room in 2004 with his website
that let college students see what other
students at the school were doing not
super impressive seeming to traditional
investors another secret weapon of mine
that was strangely well suited to Y
Combinator was that I was a very
experienced event planner events are a
crucial part of what YC does when you
fund startups in batches everything's an
event interviews are an event each
dinner is an event demo day is an event
as the alumni network crew we started
doing events for alumni to and from the
very first year we did big events like
startup school I'd been doing events for
years in my marketing jobs so I could
plan these things with one hand behind
my back probably the thing that was most
different about YC is an investment firm
though was it it felt like a family and
I was its mom I was soft and sensitive
at a time when investors tended to be
hardened and aggressive and I'll throw
in ruthless - for a couple of them that
I know I cared about how founders were
feeling if they were overwhelmed if they
were eating properly I'd counsel them on
relationships that were under strained
due to the pressure of a start-up and
I'd listen at length and help them with
their co-founder disputes and breakups
starting a startup is emotionally
draining for founders especially in the
beginning sometimes they just needed
someone to listen and luckily my entire
college career had trained me on
listening to people's social problems
and I tried to always be a straight
shooter with my advice in fact we all
were Paul is the straightest shooter I
know which is why his advice is so
valuable
he doesn't bury it new foam is amour
worse like withhold the truth in order
to preserve people's feelings and as
tough as they might found his advice at
the top they may have found his advice
at the time founders always thanked him
for his candor one thing Paul and I had
in common was they we were not driven by
money we were interested in startups and
we wanted to help people start more of
them and that was the basis for
everything we did at YC and it was what
allowed us to do something as weird as
YC in the first place
and because YC didn't have any LPS at
the time we weren't even constrained by
a vague fiduciary responsibility to
anyone and that allowed us to take more
risks with who we chose to fund and it
also allowed us to be benevolent to
failing startups and that often brought
us into conflict with investors who had
different priorities early on we had
funded a husband-and-wife team who had a
baby and they worked hard on their
startup but it was clearly failing one
of their investors tried to get them
aqua hired by a big company in in the
valley who ultimately passed paul talked
to the founders and learned that they
just wanted the security of jobs you
know so they could take a break from the
constant stress of a start-up so we
talked to the big company and got one of
them hired there and the founders were
delighted the investor on the other hand
was livid he ripped into Paul harder
than almost anyone I've ever seen
you know before Twitter
saying that Paul had blown any chance of
an aqua higher and you know it to this
day I still don't get why investors
squeeze founders over small outcomes
like this I also never cared much about
Fame or my own personal brand
I just wanted Y Combinator to succeed
one thing I've learned from Y
Combinator's at the most successful
startups grow organically out of the
founders lives and this is true in my
case too I was almost uncannily
well-suited for the kind of work that it
took to make YC successful but the
things that made me well-suited for it
were so far from the qualities that most
people associate with startup founders
I'll list them oh my gosh have I not
been have I been turning that okay sorry
I got so into my talk oh you're doing it
thank you
okay I'm gonna list the qualities pardon
that little okay wait back okay I'm
gonna list them so you can see for
yourself I was a social radar a good
event planner maternal empathetic a
straight shooter and not driven by money
or fame think how far that is from the
profile of the typical startup founder
you read in the press
I mean maternal since when was that an
important quality in a start-up founder
let alone the founder of an investment
firm yet it was critical in making YC
what it is and by the way this photo was
taken just about the same time that I
wrote Airbnb their first investment
check so that's why I wanted to share
with you my story it's not true that
every person can start every startup but
a lot more people have what it takes to
start some startup than realize it and a
lot of people perhaps all people have
some unique combination of abilities and
interests and a lot of these
combinations match some startup idea so
if you want to start a startup I
recommend you try asking yourself what's
dis ting
about you what unique combination of
abilities and interests you have and
don't edit your answers because as you
can see from my example the most
unlikely ingredients can often be the
key to the recipe in fact it may even be
that the strangest combination of
qualities are the most valuable I had a
weird combination of qualities but they
matched why see because it was such a
weird company and the most successful
startups do tend to be weird
they're usually such outliers that they
seemed preposterous at first to everyone
except the founders because the company
has grown out of their own experiences
okay so what can you learn from my story
here are nine things I'm gonna try to do
this smoothly okay nine things there's
no one successful mold for a successful
founder just because you might only see
a certain type in the news that doesn't
mean you need to turn yourself into that
do what you're genuinely genuinely
interested in and try to play to your
natural strengths a startup is so much
work that you'll give up if you're not
genuinely interested in it don't pay
attention to the mainstream's opinion of
what you're doing whether it's your
skills your idea or whatever unless
they're your users their opinion does
not matter
although do pay attention to the opinion
of your users they're important find a
co-founder with complimentary skills but
the same moral compass as you Paul and I
had the perfect combination of skills to
start something like YC we agreed on the
big questions and we each deferred to
each other's expertise on the small ones
focus on making something people want
everything follows from that in 2005
people needed a way to get a small
amount of funding easily don't let
rejection to
stratch you or hold you back you'll get
rejected in so many different ways but
you must just keep moving forward start
small so you can be nimble and open to
change we never could have pulled off
moving our operations out to Silicon
Valley in a matter of months if we had
hired people in Cambridge for example
and to this day
YC has a tradition of trying things out
on a small scale before expanding them
it's okay not to have gone to an elite
college I grew up thinking that this was
the be-all end-all you've been trained
to believe that you'll be judged by your
credentials but in a start-up it's the
users who judge you and they don't care
about your credentials they care about
your product lastly be intrepid there's
room for lots of different types of
people to be startup founders but you do
need a certain amount of boldness to
work on ideas that most people would
consider stupid and to keep going when
you're ridiculed or ignored okay let's
see where am I here we go last slide you
are a jigsaw puzzle piece of a certain
shape you could change your shape to fit
an existing hole in the world that was
the traditional plan but there's another
way that can often be better for you and
for the world to grow a new puzzle
around you that's what I did and I was a
pretty weird shaped piece so I can do it
there's more hope for you than you
realize
thank you very much
[Applause]
you